we all know Detroit's in trouble a
bankrupt city full of crumbling houses
abandoned factory buildings and a fast
dwindling population but while the
politicians unions and investors slug it
out in bankruptcy court and grasp for
their share of what little cash the city
has left ordinary citizens are left to
make do in a city with no functioning
government this is what happens when
people are left to their own devices
this is anarchy in Detroit
[Music]
you will not invest and you will not
live anyplace that's unsafe the one
thing most everyone agrees that the
government should provide is police but
in a city where emergency response times
are more than five times the national
average private security firms like
threat management have even taken the
law into their own hands
we escort people into their businesses
we make sure they safely get from their
car to their business the way we do that
is by circling their building before
they actually enter looking for threats
before they have a chance to lay in wait
for that person coming to open their
business
these escorts are $10 for each escort in
and it's very affordable we used to have
a problem here in Detroit with hijacked
cigarette trucks in one situation they
actually took the truck took hostages
and physically took them to a different
city we stopped all those hijackings and
for this other company it's 100 million
dollar company so those are the
companies that basically afford us the
ability to well and help people for free
but this isn't just some vigilante group
engaged in Wild West shoot-out we bring
to the table are a lot of heroic people
they're altruistic aliy motivated to
create change in people's lives and keep
them alive and in 20 years now for one
person came to us for help has been
injured now one person has been killed
they came to us for help and not one
person our staff has been killed police
officers and police departments are
tasked with arresting people after
they've broken the law so if you think
about it they've core values in the
metrics by which they are measured law
enforcement way of thinking is based
upon prosecution and ours is based upon
prevention Detroit's crime rate is still
five times the national average one
factor that has led its citizens to flee
the city we're about a third of the land
is vacant and abandoned attribute the
bankruptcy and all the economic issues
to a lack of safety if you don't feel
safe why would you invest in a business
there if you don't feel like your
employees are going to be safe if you
don't feel like your investment is going
to return if you have a family and you
get educated why would you not leave a
place that is not safe you would you
would leave any place that's not safe so
a lot of people left for that reason and
once the people are going the businesses
are gone there's not going to be any tax
base so you can't have a flourishing
thriving
city if it's unsafe and a lot of times
they think of it just the opposite
people in general think if we had more
money if we had a thriving City we could
then have safety which is not true in
the absence of safety you will have
nothing
[Music]
you